the joggin experience one of the things
he brought up that I wanted to discuss
is the damage that this virus does to
the lungs and to the heart as well
what there's scarring on people's heart
lungs talk about that and what if
anything can be done to try to heal
those people post infection well so what
happens is you know the virus gains
entry into the deep passages of the
lungs you know the the all the airway
spaces and then it has if you ever see a
cartoon a schematic drawing of a corona
virus it looks like a little ball with
spikes sticking out of it and those
spikes are called the S protein and
actually the vaccine that we're making
interferes with the binding of a part of
that s protein called the receptor
binding domain for binding into the
receptor so it uses those spikes the tip
of the spikes to get entry to bind to
the receptors and in the lung which is
actually an enzyme called
acetylcholinesterase and it gets into
the lung cells so the first thing that
happens is a large amount of virus is
getting into the lungs and that triggers
what's called the innate immune system
meaning your natural first-line body of
defense and it signals something called
toll-like receptors which cause a lot of
inflammation and so you're seeing a big
inflammatory response to the come to the
virus so the two components a lot of
virus causing direct damage and then the
host of the inflammatory response and
that's one of the reasons why you know
when I heard about hydroxychloroquine I
had some enthusiasm because it can maybe
suppress the inflammatory component
whether it clinically has the ability to
make a difference I just think the
jury's still out yet but so you've got
those two things going on the other
thing that's happening besides and
that's causing severe lung disease and
there's all that inflammation and it
causes a condition known as a RDS acute
respiratory distress syndrome where
there's so much inflammation and
scarring that it becomes difficult to
oxygenate the lungs and people go into
shock because of this a RDS syndrome so
that's why a lot of people
dying the other thing that happens
though and we don't really understand
the mechanism is spend a lot of reports
and by the way you can anybody can
download this there's this fantastic
preprint server called bio archive and
meta archive it's put out by Cold Spring
Harbor laboratories it's and I check it
every morning it's called bi Oh our XIV
and Men archive is meed our XIV's but if
i Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory so
scientists have been great about sharing
information they're putting all their
stuff up on these preprint servers
they're not peer reviewed yet but just
so we get information into the hands of
the scientists today but you could look
at them but one of the other things
we're seeing with that is a lot of hard
injury whether people are having heart
attacks because they're intubated in the
ICU and under stress and and they're in
shock so they're not perfusing the heart
or and we know that the old SARS virus
SARS one had the ability to go into the
heart tissue and cause what's called
myocarditis actual infection of the
heart so it's really the heart and lungs
that are getting knocked out there's
also some evidence that the virus can go
into the intestinal tract as well and so
that could actually be a potential route
of transmission being fecal oral
transmission as well so this is why
people are getting so hammered is this
direct damage from the virus and the
inflammatory component to the heart and
alone
is there any understanding of what if
anything can be done to try to heal
these people post infection particularly
like damage to the lungs yeah I think
you know there are you know there's a
question of whether steroids actually
help or hurt steroids are always a mixed
bag because steroids can suppress
inflammation and help the inflammatory
component but they also suppress the
immune response to the virus so you
could have an increased number of virus
particles potentially so people are
definitely looking into steroids other
anti-inflammatory drugs but you know
those who survive this and fortunately
most do you know you'll find that
they'll probably tell you they've been
hacking and coughing for a long time
afterwards and a lot of that is and we
see this with flu as well and other
viral pneumonia is it's not because
they're still infected with the virus
it's all that scarring is it takes the
body a long time to remodel all the scar
tissue and and before the coughing stops
so we can anticipate that happening as
well what do we think it's possible to
fully recover from this for people that
do experience these lung scarring issues
yeah I think so especially for younger
people for older people you know they
may have some permanent pulmonary
deficits but we don't know it's still
too early in this in this epidemic to
know is that a big part of what's going
on is that it's just really too early
for so many of these things the
treatments the cures the dealing with
the immune system is finding out which
people are genetically more predisposed
to by time and you know typically it can
take years and years to figure all of
this out and we're all you know
everybody's working overtime trying to
try to make a contribution figure it
figure this out I get the great news is
the the data sharing among scientists
has just been been amazing everyone's
you know putting aside the Ricoh putting
all their stuff up on bio archive met
archiving and the and the major journals
are doing incredible things also
expediting publication of paper so you
know the the flagship journals like New
England Journal of Medicine Lancet JAMA
they're all putting that stuff out
there's fast as they can you know as
ensuring quality and a level of peer
review our Plus family journals Public
Library of Science so so you know if you
if you look at the good stories that are
happening around this definitely the
data sharing the the you know journals
not conducting business as usual
recognizing that they're the stuff that
they're publishing could be life-saving
and responding to a public health crisis
and I think that that's been a nice part
of the story
[Applause]